some news that emerged on
wednesday jamie roots long time
president of the houston texans has
resigned now look i was told that he
wanted to walk out after they went off
the board to hire nick casario roots was
heavily involved in the gm search
committee they set the table with five
candidates cal mcnair and jack eastern
get together and go
to new england to fetch nick casario who
wasn't one of the five finalists that's
when roots wanted to walk that's my
understanding and they talked him into
sticking around because
amazingly they recognize
to some extent how they're being
perceived around the sports world so
they didn't want roots to walk out the
door in the middle of january and have a
higher level of dysfunction emerge but
now roots resigns uh the latest
departure and the latest piece of
evidence that jack easter be is just
taking the place oh it's taking over
yeah i mean right i mean that's all it
says i mean it really is there's nothing
more to that i mean you kind of just
laid it out perfectly right there you
got people there who are falling by the
wayside because they're going
wait this is how we're running things
now like we're gonna do it like this
okay abandon ship abort mission i'm out
of here i'm not gonna be a part of it
you know obviously i mean we've seen too
many moves here so far so uh yeah easter
bee won that civil war and he is in
control
so he won everything like on his level
and below in the football operations and
now he's forced out the one guy who was
potentially between
yeah and i i is it just a matter of time
before jack easterby has made the
president of the team and listen listen
president is so much better than
executive vp of football operations
number one it's clearly a better title
but number two
at that point you're out of focus
you're right you're less accountable
at that point i mean jamie roots has
been there 20 years this isn't like it's
been a juggernaut team but you're not
accountable when you're in that job the
only thing you're accountable to is
making money guess what nfl teams make
money you it's like brewster's million
you have to try to not make money in the
nfl and even then you still make money
so under that standard you got that job
for life yeah so yeah it won't surprise
me if easter be ascends to that title
and has full and complete insulation
from whatever mess they end up putting
on the field this year and beyond yeah i
mean it seems like it's going that way
certainly i mean really i think we knew
it was going that way
and you just brought it up but
when nick nick casario just came out of
left field out of nowhere that's when
you went whoa
i mean we hadn't heard his name i think
we heard other names and rumors through
the nfl with people we trust and all
that all of a sudden he comes out of
nowhere and you just went well that's
got to be easter bee that's got to be
and you know that that's everything
we've seen since that moment
uh points to that and obviously he has
the ear of the owner cal mcnair and
we'll see i don't know it's very odd and
i just i just still think it's a long
shot that they can figure out how to
salvage this situation with desean
watson
as mds suggested on twitter yesterday
he's our managing editor pft eventually
the front office in houston will be a
two-man operation with jackie used to be
doing stand-up comedy for cal mcnair and
hey i mean look that's the thing you've
got an audience of one it's cal mcnair
as long as cal mcnair likes you you're
the executive vp of football president
of the team and what's going to happen
what can anyone do
a short of a flat out boycott of the
texans by the fans
i i
there's no there's no real
accountability like jed york said
several years ago you can't fire the
owner no and
cal mcnair can do whatever he wants now
here's where it becomes
relevant directly to the football team
because somebody's got to make a final
decision about the sean watson the
texans are putting out privately this
notion that they still think they can
fix it with watson yeah even though
watson continues to refuse to speak with
new gm nick casario or new coach david
culley right and at some point you got
to realize you're not going to win this
with charm you're not going to win this
with patience you're not going to win
this with stubbornness
and your best move for the franchise is
to get what you can and move on my
question is
will easter be advocate and will cal
mcnair accept
an approach that consists of the team
saying
too bad play for us or play for no one
you want to sit out and pay us back 5.4
million in signing bonus money
applicable to this year do it you want
to give up your salary for this year do
it you want to tow your contract for a
full year do it we're not going to give
you we're not going to give you up even
if it is against our interest to do it
we can't have
the inmates running the inmates running
the prison oh geez yeah okay that's
right yeah damn it well the inmates do
run the asylum so they better get used
to it all right they're they're in
control here and this and would it shock
you well it'd shock you if this
organization given everything we've seen
over the past few months decides to say
we're not giving in
and you can sit out and we'll take the
heat and we don't care no yeah it would
not shock me i mean you know that would
be the stupidest approach and that seems
to be the approach they've been going
for more times than not in houston so
that would make that would make sense
they better be careful
they better be careful in this situation
players got their eyes on the houston
texans
no one really likes the organization
desean watson is getting word from his
teammates they're going get out we
understand do what you got to do he's
got the support of the players
okay they better watch out they're being
viewed as a very
unfriendly player organization and if
they botch this with desean watson and
do all this and
they're they're going to hit it one year
where they're going to have a oh we're
going to draft a quarterback and the
quarterback's going to go up no we i
don't want to go there you guys are
weird sorry so they better watch out and
handle this situation very delicately
with desean watson or it's really going
to make
you know franchise quarterbacks and that
type be very reluctant to want to go
down there or any superstar for the most
part
you're going to be relegated to draft
picks and players no one else pretty
much or or you're going to have to pay
more you're going to have to pay a
premium to get those players to come
together exactly right that's that's
gonna be your that's gonna be it yeah
exactly right i think between you know
yes the
the inmates and the asylum some of the
things we've heard dwayne brown go
through we know deandre hopkins wasn't
in love with the organization either it
was far bigger than billy o'brien there
was more issues than that and then of
course this whole year of disaster and
all that what player man when when jj
watts talking about your organization
being a little weird that that's captain
america captain america never says
anything bad about america okay so when
he's talking about you know his america
and the houston texans you know there's
issues you know it
and there's a lot of issues and i think
you explained it right that's what
they're going to be relegated to
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports